good news on Monday 44 Americans who
came into contact with a patient with
Ebola were released from their
quarantine and they're all here with us
tonight you know who you are we're gonna
have a hot tub party people it seems
like you know it seems like this crisis
is starting to fade a little right and
this one are calming down me down the
CDC says anyone flying to the u.s. from
Ebola infected countries will be
monitored for three weeks that's their
new policy yeah of course here in Los
Angeles monitoring a sick person for
three weeks is known as a reality show
[Applause]
[Music]
that's true party yeah yeah the FBI is
investigating three teenage girls from
Denver who were trying to join Isis yeah
yes yes the teenage girls were
apprehended after they announced a jihad
against that [ __ ] Ashley is going on
taylor swift's in the news due to a
technical glitch Taylor Swift's new
single was released as eight seconds of
static and it still went to number one
on iTunes that's true in seconds of
static and here's how good she is I
can't stop humming it
[Music]
that's also my sort of vampire zombie
yeah yeah a diet pill endorsed by dr. oz
that's right a diet pill endorsed by dr.
oz was found to be based on bogus
scientific research yeah people are
shocked that you can't trust a TV doctor
named after a lying wizard his name is
oz politicians in Miami have passed a
resolution to split Florida into two
states yes
yeah the two states would be known as
geezer Ville and methyl Vania or an old
guy on that right it could be an overlap
yeah an old guy who'd do maths it's a
great thing about this country
smooth jazz musician Kenny G and I got
your attention don't do that
smooth jazz musician Kenny G was in Hong
Kong showing support for the protestors
there yeah Kenny G played three notes
the Chinese government immediately
surrendered to Hong Kong just collect
whatever you want
a new report on government waste
includes I can't believe this 350,000
dollars to study massages for rabbits
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
to study massages for rabbits yeah and
you guessed it every single rabbit
massage comes with a hoppy ending
[Applause]
who got scared at the end that's what I
want to know did it really frighten you
good yes good it should now there's spit
all over the lens
you